oh you're sad because toys-r-us was the
greatest neural closed we'll check this
wearing an eight-story
wait a minute toll toy store home in
Akihabara pen featuring cyclo Jesus
which looking at found Pokemon green
which is amazing because it was a kid I
heard the legend of Pokemon green but I
it wasn't available in the United States
this is like mint in box 7 bucks you
should get it yes so for your reference
this place is called
mondo rocky and it is awesome but Aki
Harbor is actually full of stuff like
this and I'm just trying not to spend
all of my money let's go check out an
arcade
oh I'm 7s
you are such an enabler
no sex officially failed I'm a failure
miles is telling boyfriend this how many
give it an attempt Oh No
you're welcome buddy we lost lane
been in this battle pod for like
you know what good I'll cave makes me
want to do look at more retro games but
seriously I actually bought these I
figured that I would maybe like frame
them these are all of the original
Pokemon games in Japanese I also bought
this excellent egg shut don't know why
this Ninja Batman figure made by Sigma
you guys know me you will know that I
really like collecting weird Batman
stuff this black and white son Goku I
also collect a lot of Dragonball figures
and I love that this one doesn't have
any color and last but not least this
very cute terrarium Pikachu toy Wow 70
yen that means it's about five dollars
70 cents but this has a chance of coming
with any of the stuff on the sides I'm
hoping for the chars on but I'm not up
in this one right now
that's less sticky tape this is an
unnecessary amount of sticky tape
hoo-boy bade Lord Charizard that he may
bless us on this fine day but I like all
of them
honestly I picked this one because even
if I don't get the Charizard of
everything on this boss is really cute
I'm seeing some yellow I think it's
gonna be side up who was my favorite
Pokemon when I was a kid probably the
oldest like collectible that I have is
this Psyduck that I got when I was on
them 6 confirmed it is Psyduck let's
open it up
got all the packaging out of here put
the little base together which i think
just fits in here
now try and tell me God isn't one of
cutest things you've ever seen
you know I did buy one more thing but I
need Blaine here to show it to you guys
he went to the gym so when he returns so
I just got out of the shower my skin is
always terrible when I travel so this is
a Pikachu
oh I look just like Pikachu Blaine are
you ready I look very cute so I got
Blaine and Eevee are you ready yes how
you feeling look like a leather face I
know it's terrible skin Pikachu and put
his alright skin on his face it kind of
stings a little when she's weird doing I
don't know what I'm supposed to do with
the ears like they just kind of this
sort of sit there oh god yeah boy look
you're about to put ham on my face oh
it's winking and everything I was cold
but it's one of them okay you're gonna
need to lay back because you know this
doesn't stick to your face as well
because they're so beautiful
close your eyes mmm just like Eve he's
here impossible I love you so I was
thinking would just have you know like a
chill night okay
[Music]
so we visited Kojima Productions which
is where death stranding is being made
but they are hard at work making the
game literally right now so we couldn't
show you anything off the studio but we
did get this cool swag bag I'll show you
some stuff from this later and right now
we add the pokemons Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so uh typhoon just hit Tokyo which was
saying so they have a pizza called the
Quatro chase sorry
the Quatro tastes of Japan which
features all four of their special
Japanese flavors which only runs until
mid-september which is when we're here
you're Spanish so you're part this is
what's gonna get Wilder okay it's the
easiest way to try every one of these
Japanese delicacies grilled beef tongue
steamed meat dumpling Taiwan's soup list
noodle Sakura shrimp gratine this is if
you order a large this is a $43 pizza oh
my god it can't even load that so
there's so much cheese look at it trying
to get in all the cheese pixels it
simply can't do a website I will chip in
a little bit extra because I know I'm
the one that's really pushing for this
bizarre Domino's experience if there's
peer pressure ease in can I get the
review on the beef tongue pizza don't be
jelly alrighty so back from Kojima
Productions we have this Luden's scoff
I'm not gonna open any of this stuff up
just because I want to make sure it gets
back to the US safely with me if I make
it back to the US but we'll get to that
this holographic postcard don't know if
you can see that on camera
it's actually really good holographic
stuff can sometimes suck but this looks
more 3d than holographic it's it's very
cool this is a mug I don't know what
color I got so I'm gonna do this one a
white Kojima Productions mug good size
for drinking green tea I think and what
I think is the coolest thing in here is
these chopsticks that they say right up
here this one says Kojima Productions
this one says from sapience to Luden's
and the thing about these is they're
worth about $100 made by a master
chopstick maker and it comes with its
own sort of chopstick bag that you can
reuse that you can wash but I don't know
if I'm going to do that I feel like I
value this so highly as a collector's
item that I might like frame them or
something but yeah I have bought more
stuff I didn't want to just like have
this video be me showing you stuff but I
bought some stuff at the Ghibli museum
one allowed to film anything there
bought some stuff at the Pokemon Center
but I don't think I'll be vlogging much
for the rest of the trip because we go
to Kyoto and Hakone and Osaka and I just
kind of want to you know make sure that
I enjoy those places which a less video
game toy orientated but I might be stuck
in Japan there are issues of my visa the
US Embassy currently has my passport and
it won't give it back to me they will at
some point I just don't know when so I'm
kind of a sitting duck waiting hoping I
get my possible back before my flight
back to the US but it's seeming pretty
unlikely they said it could be up to 90
days so I'm just kind of stuck in Japan
until they decide to give me my passport
back which is not great I'm hoping that
they only have it hostage for a few days
rather than for several months because I
don't know what I'm gonna do about a
combination but right now literally no
timeline hope you guys have enjoyed this
very weird vlog I'm Alana and I will see
you all next time